bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got gary
here with me thank you so much for doing
this sir
thank you for having me on and it's a
pleasure to be here for sure you are
uh deep deep deep down the uh no code
rabbit hole we're gonna get to that in a
minute but
you before this had a very long story
career in the traditional finance
uh industry so walk us through kind of
what you did
before you started on cork yeah i mean
if i go way back and we could do the
wavy lines would be
um literally back in fifth grade queen's
public schools
the days you could actually leave school
and go home for lunch which i can't even
imagine my kids leaving school and going
home for lunch so
in those days i used to walk out of
school myself fifth grade and walk to my
father's publishing business which was a
few blocks away in queens
and i would sit and play with punk punch
card machines index my comic books
i and then the next year in sixth grade
he had pascal and fortran and
and i was loving this idea back then
that
i could communicate and make a machine
do something the art of the possible
what what could you do could imagine it
and
that's kind of how i grew up in life
which was could i actually continue to
go down this journey of
communicating with machines in different
languages that someone cryptic made up
that looks like ancient greek
and uh instead of doing the
entrepreneurial
like my whole family had done i actually
said wouldn't it be exciting
to work on wall street i got the wall
street bug
and i'm a new yorker by heart stayed in
new york my whole time through college
and then
of course wall street was a natural
progression and i spent about 20 years
on wall street creating technology
solutions communicating with machines to
do trading
to do execution to do mutual funds sales
performance accounts receivables and
and just um again the art of the
possible was always what i love to do i
had about six patents
in financial services five of them are
still in production
today for citigroup uh fortune 50
company where i worked
and then i joined another fortune 50
company metlife as global cio
and i walked into a role in 2012 with 10
000 developers
in 47 countries you know spending over a
billion a year
and um going back to where i started
what i
missed when i started that role and what
i missed even in citigroup was
the art of the possible seemed like it
was gone so the days
when you would sit there and and create
a solution for a business and solve a
problem
it seemed like we were spending more and
more money with less and less output
coming out
and and it wasn't just me it was you'd
hear from my peers in the industry
uh all the consulting groups would say
93
of the the projects being worked on fell
to deliver any value
so anthony like if you're in business
you talk about two metrics to the board
you talk about and i've done this
hundreds of times you say
are we delivering on time or on a value
on dollar
basically and that's what they call it's
on time or on budget two things
and you know it means nothing it's like
walking into a furniture and saying
hey i like the couch and like i'm gonna
uh buy it it's
yes it's 12.99 i'll purchase 12.99 so
that's the price i paid and
i want it shipped next week and it
arrives next week and it gets into your
house and it doesn't fit
and it's just the wrong couch and it's
just you're miserable the reality what i
saw in technology for 25
years before creating a cork was the
business was pretty miserable as to
what was coming out because they didn't
know what they needed until that couch
walked into the house and when it walked
in it was too late
so the metrics of on time and on budget
mean nothing
and that's created on cork to basically
to fix the world let's call it
and just a small little challenge there
we're we're going after a 500 billion
dollar
total addressable market and that's the
start we'll go above that after but
that's kind of where
where the journey's been on that's
awesome and so you guys are in the no
code business what the hell is no code
mean
so i love the question because
everyone's like there's code somewhere
show us the code show us where it is and
and the reality is
um i have a team of engineers i've got
about 100 of the top engineers i've ever
met in the world and like i worked with
400 000 people at citigroup and 70 000
at metlife and
you know we collected about 100 of the
best engineers across
all industries they code there's no
question that they're coding
but what they're coding looks to a user
what we call a business engineer is the
term we came up with
as a legal block and so
it's they're coding and basically hiding
the code from someone to say
oh you want to basically do a payment
using stripe i mean what an
amazing story this week on stripe and
the results you want to use stripe to
basically get a payment
for a new subscriber in your company you
could drag in you know a text box for
first name you could drag in stripe
as a component we already work with them
and integrate with them oh you want to
use your bank account bring implied
and all these components we code
the reusable component that you simply
drag and drop in so it's a visual
designer tool
and what's different about us than a wix
maybe which is no code wix is no code
and people been using it for a long time
for building websites
is what we drag and drop could replace
the most complex trading platforms
transaction systems 20 million
transactions a second type systems
exchanges at this point we look at
financial services where we started and
public sector and healthcare
and we look at these sectors and say we
could basically handle 100
of what they're doing today with code
without a question
without with the most complex use cases
you could imagine without
anything more than dragging and dropping
and so so no code specifically is
there's no ancient greek there's no and
for the first time
you're getting scale at it and we don't
generate code
we don't let you inject code and which
goes against
all principles everything that's out
there today and
all the technology is supporting
engineers coding
we're basically saying it's a whole new
way to create software it's so
really what you're doing is if somebody
uh kind of uses a consumer example
something like a squarespace i want to
build a website i don't know how to code
i can go in i can drag
and drop i can add functionality uh
really what i'm doing is kind of taking
these containerized
snippets of code and i'm adding that
functionality
you know kind of as i see fit to my
customized needs
but really what's happened is it was
almost like the code was pre-written
for me and therefore i can just use that
uh to do it without having to have the
technical knowledge to actually write
the individual codes that fair
you it's very fair that's exactly right
yep and as you think
through this most people know
squarespace they know other sorts of
what i'll call consumer
uh facing technology right things that
i want to build that have uh maybe not
mission critical elements to it
uh but my understanding is what you guys
are doing is you're building these no
code solutions for
some of the most important software and
some of the most kind of mission
critical software for our business uh
and for very important
large um you know businesses and so how
does that change the way you think about
building some of these no code tools
how reliable they have to be how
resilient they have to be
and just how you know frankly usable
they have to be from a user experience
standpoint inside these large
organizations
yeah actually so the words are faster
better cheaper what we always hear so
anthony if you were in a corporation
you would hear and you were my business
partner i'd say and you said gary i want
you to build this great onboarding
system to onboard new customers to our
bank and it should be fast and efficient
and i basically would look at you and
say that's great do you want it faster
or better or cheaper
choose two so what we did was very
unique when we said no code
means no code you could inject no code
you generate
really what we're saying is scale and
applications for the first time which
means
that you're on the same version of code
so you start building today i'm going to
make this up you're going to start
building an onboarding solution today
for your customers using oncork
you're going to be using technology on
the same version of software as
every major bank every major financial
institution every hospital
every health care provider and insurance
company you're starting where they
already left off
which is the entire difference
fundamental difference between
us and everything before us what i mean
by that is
you could take any solution today take a
crm package which is simple everyone's
been talking crm software as a service
for years and years
they provide crm as a simple base and
then you code on top of it
which means if you needed a crm and your
partner needed a crm
you're both starting from 50 and you're
coding 50
and now you're locked in to a technology
and you're not getting the benefit of
what your partner did versus what you
did
and basically you could separate that
into divisions of a company
every company division is starting with
ground zero
and they're not benefiting each other
they're not benefiting the company or
the industry
what we did was we said look no one else
could code but us that's it
we're the ones coding the components and
what it does mean is that
when a new business requirement comes in
for example uh
someone needed a slider to be able to do
a loan we we built
loan software to do loans we built the
rent relief software just launched as a
product
last week and so a slider is something
you see on the screen when you build the
slider
someone needed it when we created that
component slider every customer
automatically got it
because they can't inject codes so
they're
guaranteed to work on the latest version
of software they're automatically being
upgraded
there's no more legacy there's no more
hey you're using java
using c sharp or c plus or any other
code out there it's gone
you know it's basically you're
guaranteed to be on the same version of
software which means
that you're going to benefit from the
community of users
all on the same platform all testing all
cyber security testing and pen testing
the same software
that's what no code means to us that's
exactly what it means in the difference
for us
so how does this change uh kind of the
software development process so inside
of an organization obviously i still
have software engineers
now i have these new code tools how do i
change the way that i build
products yeah it's a great point so
today if you step into an organization
and say
hey how are you building software today
you can have a business analyst that
writes a word document
they're going to give it to an
engineering team who's going to work
with a chief architect
to come up with a schematic a blueprint
and here's the technology we'll use
integration points they'll start coding
and you'll develop test plans off to the
side and the test plans will be based on
what the business requirements said
the test plans will start and basically
find out that technology after a year
of coding didn't deliver what they
thought they'd get
and this is in what we call the
waterfall approach traditional waterfall
approach
and then at the end of the year
technology would be on a become lawyers
i've done it when you become an attorney
you're like well business let me show
you this is what you said you wanted
this is what i did
you know you didn't tell me you needed a
button on the screen to submit and save
so we didn't put a button on the screen
to save so the application doesn't save
like that's what's happening today and i
know that's a little bit extreme
on the agile approach which i was one of
the first pioneers of agile in large
corporations
and the idea of moving faster in the
businesses at the table
it's really good for delivering
incremental value but it gets to the
point that we celebrate success hey we
built this
and as a business partner you go but it
doesn't do anything you know it's not
yet what i need i needed that other
stuff that's in the backlog
so with unquark what we've done is if
you think about
coding we replaced the coding aspect
and now business users could be
technologists the people coding could be
the reality is the person writing the
word document could now do 80 percent of
the working on quark without any help
they could actually start to configure
the screens and the rules and the
integrations
and they could do the design they then
work with a technologist
to do that last piece all in on cork the
integration mapping the data mapping to
the legacy systems to the core systems
the books and records
um all the complexity around that that's
done in on inside uncork net outside is
a unified platform
and the reality is what we're finding is
we're shortening the coding time we're
200 times
faster than a java developer we could
sit down and show you if a java
developer was taking this long to do it
we're 200 times faster than that
overall because you're still doing
requirements gathering
you're still doing testing you're still
doing test plans you're still
most importantly the business is
changing requirements on the fly
throughout the entire program
and that's that's expected that's so
all that results in when we're finding
about a three times faster
agile project agile is in it's going to
be incremental let's go as fast as we
can
and there's no risk to deployment no
risk to change
if you didn't get it right the first
time we'll get it right the second time
immediately here
that's what's different it's also
resulting in three times cheaper is what
we're hearing back from customers than
anything they've seen so that's
three times the metric no one's ever
achieved in technology before
you've heard 30 percent better or fifty
percent better sometimes
but three times but most importantly uh
anthony what we've actually now done
we came up with what we call lining of
code equivalency
so if you were going to code this a
traditional way with
you know javascript or node or html or
whatever you're going to use
we actually came up with a way to take
an encore app and generate the estimated
lines of code it would have taken
and so in today in production we're
running for customers you know
80 90 million lines of code equivalency
already with 350 million lines of code
in uat
and about a billion lines of code
equivalency and staging but all going
through
to production but we were able to use
that to estimate defects
and a defect people don't talk about
defects but
for every like 50 lines of code there's
one defect traditionally that's
available there i mean squiggly brackets
are hard to get right in semicolons and
it's it's names and everything's case
sensitive for those who don't know it's
hard to code
i mean i look at banks that talk about
you can read about banks telling
their that they're going to train their
traders on python
and i look at that and i'm like you want
sympathy from them you're trying to
basically create sympathy just it's
nothing to do with productivity it's
like you want them to feel bad for you
because it's hard to code
that's not what that's answer is but um
but realities it's hard to
that one line of defect one defect for
every 50 lines of code
is an estimate we're 600 times higher
quality so
the faster better cheaper it's three
times three times and 600 times higher
quality
that's the difference that we bring to
the table versus
everyone else in software today every
other company out there
so when you think about the differences
that you're making it's really on the
back end it's in the software
development process
it's in the integration into the
business do the users of the software if
i'm somebody who's signing up through
that payment flow if i'm somebody who's
leveraging it as an internal or external
customer do i
tell any difference between code that
was kind of custom written versus the no
code product
no so we are so proud to be invisible to
the world
so you might be using us in a bank today
you might be using us
you know in health care you might be
using us in public sector or insurance
we're completely invisible you'll never
know on cork exists
there was a really cool charity i joined
as an advisor called play on where they
performed
cbs the end of the year last year
there's a prime time special we put on
with
all the best music stars john bon jovi
and others
the entire cycle play on live.org is 100
on cork
and you would never know it's there
except we put for the first time powered
by own cork it's the first stamp we ever
put on any site
because it was a charity that we helped
create but um
but you'll never know it's us other than
that and so the idea is
we're a platform to create software no
one ever should know
we exist you shouldn't know we're
storing your data we're encrypting your
data
we're doing it in a way which um banks
trust us with their customer data when
they wouldn't trust
any other technology and because we come
from that world we understand that world
and so so with that um it's done very
differently we
don't exist we take on your experience
your user experience
um so in some cases anthony like so new
york city
i think it's the best case you know how
fast we can move
so you've used as a consumer you used
products like gofundme and seamless web
before
i guarantee i'm on those products both
all the time great consumer products
here we are we had a new york city call
from the commissioner common march
6 last year and said how quick could
uncork stand up a cobit tracking system
to track all 20 million tri-state
residents that might call 3-1-1
and all consumers who want to
self-report symptoms
because this covert thing's coming and
this time was we were joking before the
call and then but like this time i was
just coming back from presenting
montgomery southern california i was
coming back to l.a there was
people wearing masks and i thought they
were crazy i'm like what's what's going
on here
so so we actually received a call on
friday at 5 p.m on monday morning we
demoed a production ready secured system
that already went through pen testing
vulnerability assessment performance
assessing to handle all 20 million
requests and we became the system of
record
and we basically worked with new york
city to deploy that within a week which
is unheard of to go
without one line of code and then what
happened was
it succeeded and this is typically why
we have like 145
net dollar retention rate which is
incredible succeeded and we have a call
to say
um how quick could you create a donation
tracking system like gofundme
so we created with them we enabled new
york city to create on our platform
within three days they created gofundme
equivalent donation site to collect 150
million dollars of donations
without one engineer standing up and the
coolest thing was this is what i get to
tell my kids about which was
um you know your they came back and said
we need to get food to senior citizens
and if you were in new york city which
you were if you
ever saw a national guard loading a box
into a taxi at any point there's all
these clubs in brooklyn and new york
city
and that was powered by uncork 100
we basically created the equivalent of
seamless web
the company and new york city created it
on
the court they new york city was able to
hire about 18 000 delivery drivers that
were unemployed
to basically deliver food to seniors in
need
and i think the number i heard was it
delivered 75 million food orders
75 million so whenever i see on amazon
which was like we delivered 14 million
meals
we actually and uncork enabled 75
million meals
in just a few months that it was you
know there which to me
software it's back to the art of
possible it's got to enable us to live a
better life
i kind of feel like software today is uh
like middle school years with acne like
it's
like it's uncomfortable you walk into a
hospital or a doctor's office you're
giving paper
and a pen still today so
how does this change the recruiting
right so when i start to think about
exactly what you're talking about here
normally if you want to build this type
of
uh kind of reach this type of efficacy
inside of any sort of software related
company you'd have to go hire not a
hundred engineers you'd probably have to
hire you know a thousand or two thousand
engineers
so not only are you at uncork not having
to have as big of a team as maybe you
would have had to have
uh but also then you're going to these
companies and you're saying hey we can
actually lessen your dependence
on uh kind of your core engineering team
those with the software skills
themselves and so
is this something that becomes prevalent
enough to actually make a dent in
recruiting where
uh the software uh engineers they're
still valuable but now there's this like
business engineer position that becomes
super valuable or how do you look at
that from a personnel standpoint
and the impact of the customers that you
guys serve it's amazing i think
i come as a cio right so i actually ran
fortune 50 technology groups my whole
life
we're selling to the business about 80
of the time today
and so the business is basically saying
we need a solution we have never seen a
solution we've been waiting years for
the solution this is the solution
i could get it in three weeks four weeks
and i'm done
so a lot of times that's actually how we
see the sell now with that said
um you could look at our investors
goldman's tax little seriously
they were an investor before you know
capital g with google
little series b black our plato series c
we have
um when you look at our clients that we
talk about like liberty mutual
was our first client ever and it's a for
you know fortune 100 company
and you look at the money's medical
center is our first healthcare company
provider and they're the largest
employer in brooklyn
we always started with the most complex
biggest companies to solve
so everything else is easy in those
cases i mentioned
the technologists realized that
their their value is to deliver
technology as fast as they can to the
business
and they're visionary technologists who
say
i know that if you could do this you
could do 90 of what i do today
then i could devote 100 of my engineers
to something better
than they're not doing today so i i
definitely there's no shortage of
engineers
anyone saying is short of engineers it's
just the wrong technologies that's what
it comes down to
however i also wouldn't say that we're
going to
be the cause of 50 000 engineers in a
bank to disappear tomorrow because the
reality is
those 50 000 engineers in a bank could
be creating
the new algorithms that we can't even
envision yet
and what's the art of the possible if
you're able to take someone who's moving
a button around the screen
and has a master's degree in computer
science with 10 000 hours
what if you took that person him or her
and made him responsible to build a new
algorithm
to detect fraud you know or detect
like that's where the that's what they
should be focusing on
so the way i see it is like we're
empowering the engineers to basically
take on bigger and better
responsibilities
freeing them up to do things they should
be doing instead of what i would call
the misery that they're loaded down with
today
well this is the whole idea that
basically machines will replace all the
rudimentary kind of elementary tasks
that
uh we have and what it does is you know
has it as it has done many many times
over
uh the history of human uh existence is
it will free humans up to do the more
creative harder to replicate
uh type work right so whether you look
back and you say hey farmers
uh you see like 90 plus percent of the
population had to be farmers
well now we've got kind of the mass
production of food and so that freed
people up it didn't make them
not be able to make a living and freed
them up to actually go do more creative
things that machines had a harder time
doing and so that's essentially what
you're saying here
is uncork's gonna remove a lot of the
the elementary
or repetitive type work uh and instead
those same engineers now can go do the
more complex things that maybe uncork
hasn't gotten a chance yet to uh
with no code absolutely i always tell
the story of like i guess it's the 1500s
when a queen was presented by an
inventor of the new sewing machine
called the art you know and
she's like what are all my little people
doing this today gonna do for work so
she exiled him to paris to die in
poverty where he did
and that's a true story like in reality
that it's time to move forward with this
because for 30 years
i still look back at the punch card
machine i was indexing comic books on or
the pascal and fortran
nothing's changed it's still even with
all the discussion of cloud computing
cloud computing it's amazing it's scaled
at the infrastructure level
it made infrastructure a software
problem that's it
the reality is you're still coding you
know the cloud computer
companies are still saying host your
code in our cloud
they're not saying here's a way to get
rid of the code and so
it's time for a shift because we make
cloud computing irrelevant
we actually we host it for you the
database is done for you there's no more
security
there's nothing else to worry about it's
just it's all out of the box
got it and so when you start to think
about kind of the big challenges moving
forward what are the biggest obstacles
you guys face
so so number one is this the category
that
was created years back low code no code
absolutely every company that's 15 years
old is suddenly rebranding themselves
and remarketing themselves to be in this
category and the category itself
is not defined properly because the
category has historically been
plagued by a concept that if you enable
the engineer to code that's a feature
that's needed
and that was true 10 years ago 15 years
ago you know
the reality is we've proven that you
know it's not true anymore it's actually
the harm
so i would say like this whole concept
of categorizing software and fitting
software into buckets is incorrect
and you know it's kind of like the
iphone the iphone was a divergence
convergence device
and the first iphone reviews were
horrible i mean they were literally like
this this guy's not
this is no one's going to use this
device we're kind of at that point right
now where
you know everyone's rebranding
themselves as a smartphone around us in
many ways
and reality is we're saying everyone's
looking at the wrong category
we're actually it's it's not just a tool
and a toolbox for an engineer to do what
they did yesterday do it tomorrow
it's to free up the engineer to do
something completely different so
to me it's around that categorization is
what i'm really
fascinated by and that's where we're um
i'm really interested about what we
enable in the future
anthony so my my view is i left the
corporate world to basically fix it
it was what could we do once we actually
fix the problems out there and what i
experienced
to me it's about imagine if data quality
was
perfect and it was entered only one time
that's it and everything worked meaning
meaning you were born and
your your son or daughter was born in a
hospital and on cork was the system of
record
used to create the birth certificate
immediately i should be able to go to
your insurance company and say hey you
use admin insurance we're going to add
your
daughter to the policy and by the way
would you like a gerber life insurance
policy and by the way would you like to
add them as a beneficiary to your will
by the way would you like and i could
continue that journey to say that
congratulations they got a driver's
license
would you like us to add them to the
policy here the insurance you bought a
home would you like
and i just think about how disconnected
the world is right now
and the data i mean there's nothing more
than the pandemic to show
us how we are not digital we are
definitely
in seventh grade with acne as far as it
goes
in technology and that's that's what
we're excited to change
when you think out 25 years from now is
everything
no code uh where does this go
what does that world look like so i'm
hoping it's five years out but 25 it's
going to be interesting to see i i'm
25 years we got to have jets and cases
come on in like that's i'm waiting for
like the jets in case you open it up you
jump in and you can fly somewhere
um i keep waiting for that day and uh my
youngest eight-year-old says he's going
to invent
the real flying car and it's going to be
powered by lightning i love this idea
but that's what i'm hoping 25 years is
but
reality is as it comes to code and no
code you know
even in five years from now i would hope
that we start to look back and look at
the company and say
first off what are you doing to address
your legacy
so oncork is the first solution there is
no more legacy
what i mean by anthony is if you created
a solution today on cork
and tomorrow there's a holographic
interface for you to interact with your
bank
when we create that one interface in a
holographic device you automatically got
it with no change to your application
you're automatically going to be moving
so we moved all customers over from
angular to react because react was
better performance to the client
not a single customer knew it even
occurred for the first time that project
in a bank guaranteed is 20 million
dollars
and it fails every time we moved all
customers from docker to kubernetes
behind the scenes to do
and better deployments faster no one
knew it even occurred
it's just invisible so we could migrate
customers in one fell swoop to the
latest technologies the more legacy
i look back at what's happening today in
corporations and i think about
robotics rpa and
it's a it's a technology that's been
around for 20 years it's putting a layer
on top of the technology that's there
the legacy and saying let's push it
under the cover further
and pretend it's okay so
i'm hoping in 25 years there's no more
legacy that's what my wish for the world
would be
you know what companies need to start
being their stock price should be
evaluated based on how quickly they
address
legacy technology because it will impact
that stock price
guaranteed in five years or ten years
if they just can't simply keep hiding it
behind technology
instead of addressing are we at a point
now where basically everyone has to have
a
no code strategy right you know i talk a
lot in the crypto world if everyone
needs a bitcoin strategy
is it now that every corporation needs a
no code strategy
so it's so funny you you want any boards
i gotta ask
you're you must be um but a few
so so as a cio who used to present the
public boards
i could tell you what's happening right
now is the boards are starting to ask
their
ceo and their leadership team so what
are you doing about this low code no
code space which popped up
and it you know it's it's what are we
doing there and
what the technologists who i would call
i'm going to call them more
technologists who are more worried about
their job
than they are worried about the
shareholders and the customer
will basically very quickly look to pick
a solution in that space which enables
them to continue doing what they're
doing today
which is code so they'll look for a
solution that lets them
inject their code in that system and
anthony the best way to say it in cloud
computing which everyone knows cloud and
the idea behind it
it would it's basically like me taking
an old server from downstairs that's 10
year old dell server with 20
you know 32 core cpu and it's a great
server but
i'm going to pick it up and drive it to
amazon's data center and ask them to
rack it for me in their cloud
and no one would ever do that no one
would ever think like
if i give them this server could they
rack it for me i know there's no spare
parts it's going to break
it's going to be insecure it can't be
patched can't be supported
no one knows how to support it it won't
be compliant or compatible
why would i ever do that and yet that's
exactly what we're doing today when we
take
our code and host it in someone else's
offer it's exactly the same thing here's
my legacy code go put it in your legacy
environment
so when you think about what's happening
today in that space
to me at the board level they're saying
yes what are we doing here
we're seeing technologists select
software that keeps them
employed more than changes the company
and revolution we had a client yesterday
go i could keep with my incumbent low
code provider
a crm tool and i could keep with that or
i could choose on cork and revolutionize
the business that's the difference and
i love the conversation i love the
battle there and um
with that i would simply ask the
business you anyone listening to the
business to your
your podcast who simply say ask the
question simply ask the technologists
you know number one if we choose that
solution
is it going to upgrade automatically to
the latest technology or are we going to
have legacy tomorrow here
that's it one simple question and
there's only one technology
at the end of that that doesn't which is
us so it's pretty cool to be in that
spot it's a good question for you then
if uh
it's a good question for me we're gonna
try it yeah i mean anthony the other
question which i love is
you know board members if you think
about how businesses get compensated
or like product managers get compensated
it's based on delivery
it's based on outcome it's based on
value
if you think about technologies at least
historically what i've witnessed
is technologists are compensated based
on a budget size
how many people work for you how big is
your budget is the more money you
personally make at the end of the year
bonus
it's exactly contrary to
productivity and efficiency and it has
nothing to do with value
so if we change the way we actually
compensate to say it's based on your
value bring the company
technologists will stop trying to hire
engineers for the sake of headcount
and budget size that's kind of where so
so it's my own
it's my own belief there that's a
personal belief that i've seen in the
past
i'd love to see change makes uh makes
sense to me uh before i let you go ask
everyone the same three questions and
then you have to ask me one to finish up
the first is what's the most important
book that you've ever read
so i mean look enjoyable book is uh
ready player one just because i love the
80s and i love the idea that that was
the whole book premise but as far as a
book recommended i do like barking up
the wrong tree
barking up the wrong tree by eric i just
you know this idea that every
every day we're actually going to wake
up there's gonna be a new problem to
solve make the game about problem
problem solving make it fun to solve
problems
make it so that we actually that's it's
actually what life is about
is solving problems solving puzzles my
mornings my morning start off with me
doing ken ken or suduko at the hardest
level possible just to basically say
my brain's going to get a little bit
activated and i know that it might not
solve the problem i might have to give
up but i'm going to try my best to do it
and i'll try again tomorrow if i don't
i love it uh next question is brought to
you by our friends over at eight sleep i
sleep five or six hours now i sleep on
their thermoregulated bed
i turn it basically as cold as i
possibly can like an ice cube sleep
eight or nine hours and
uh they have fully converted me to this
like sleep religion and how important it
is
uh what is your sleep schedule and how
has that changed over time
so um when i created on cork i probably
wasn't doing that i was probably doing
about two or three hours a night of
sleep and i do remember those well and
of course with three kids you remember
those days also
i could tell you i am a six to eight guy
so i need a minimum of six
and max eight if it's more than eight i
don't feel great and i need that coffee
in the morning if it's six i'm kind of
okay
and seven is probably my max number i do
one thing as a routine though anthony so
i mentioned ken ken in the morning like
to me i'm
candy crush right before bed because
there's no game you could basically
reset your brain then candy crush where
you don't have to think and
it's probably the best life lessons in
candy crush which is you know
it's about luck it's about trying the
same thing over and over again
you're going to basically go insane this
definition goes if you keep thinking
it's going to get a different result
every time you try something it's
definition of insanity
and uh and you know it's basically just
something to watch things explode which
is nothing wrong with that before going
to bed
i love it last question you get asked me
one is aliens are you a believer or
non-believer
believer and non-believer i i have to
believe that we are not the only
civilization
out there um at all so absolutely
and i would be excited by one day being
able to see that there are
are they coming down to earth i can't
see why they'd be here they'd they'd be
here with masks and covered right now so
why would we ever
but uh but absolutely believe that we
are not the only civilization for sure
what are you anthony go ahead
and that that question i got to hear oh
i'm definitely a believer i i don't know
if we're going to see them
uh but for sure we uh we definitely are
not the only intelligent life in
probably our galaxy let alone all the
other galaxies
what is your favorite book can i ask
what is your favorite um
so favorite is probably a little bit
different i always say like the three
most impactful books for me were
rich dad poor dad rich's man in babylon
and think and grow rich but those
were like personal finance type books
that i wrote when i was younger uh now i
would say that um
by the most important book and most
impactful book i almost think of it as
like the bible of investing
is uh the dao of capital uh written by
uh mark spitznagel sounds a
a great one i'm gonna go order that i
haven't heard that that's an awesome one
very cool well thank you thank you thank
you for having me on and this is tons of
fun
absolutely where can we send people to
find you on the internet or find out
more about on cork
yes so on kirk.com unqrrk.com and just
you know it's
not a wine company we disappointed a lot
of investors early on you can imagine
we're walking in to do the pitch and
they're like wait you're not consumer
goods you're not
um and so we we were all about uncorking
the competitive advantage that lies in
great companies so we don't compete with
you we enable you to basically do better
and on court
we couldn't afford the c which was half
a million dollars to buy the domain and
instead it was a 1495 purchase of
godaddy
and um and that was that's kind of where
we are and of course everyone's welcome
look me up on linkedin i would love it
connect with me on linkedin and
you'll find me there awesome awesome
gary listen thank you so much for doing
this you guys built an amazing company
i'm a big fan so keep it up and we'll do
it again in the future i
can't wait thank you anthony thanks
again have a great day